any concept in computing is inevitably
an abstraction of a more complicated
concept underneath if you think about
using a computer you're clicking around
on the screen and the things that you're
clicking on the screen are widgets so if
we look at a title bar like this then
the three buttons up here
those are widgets on the computer screen
for most people I think that's where
their understanding of computing begins
and ends right but obviously when I push
that button that prompts the computer to
go away and do something how does it
turn that input into some electronic
stimuli if every time we wanted to
describe how the clicks button on the
screen works I had to talk to you in
terms of electrons bouncing around
inside a wire and explain the quantum
mechanics of a transistor then it would
take an enormous amount of time and so
instead of talking about quantum
mechanics in a transistor I I abstract
that idea and I say look a transistor is
just a switch and that switch can be
open or closed and the electrons
traveling down a wire they're either
there or they're not there which is a 1
or a 0 and in numberphile we talked
about ones and zeroes of a lot so so we
won't go back into that but but it's
just numbers
traveling down while most computers are
32-bit and 64-bit these days we have a
series of wires parallel wires which run
together and we give those a fancy name
called a bus and so it's ones and zeros
traveling down a bus and they represent
numbers and then it's a question of
where what are those numbers mean were
those numbers they come back to be a
computer program which is a series of
very specific instructions still quite a
big thing to ask somebody to start with
a bunch of switches and ones and zeros
and turn those into something which
takes two numbers and adds them together
right that that is a difficult question
and so we take the the switches and the
ones and zeros and we turn those into
thing called logic gates things which do
simple human understanding on
instructions so anding two numbers
together or or in two numbers
really actually quite simple concepts
but the point is that that you take the
switches and you abstract those into a
gate you take the gate and you abstract
that into an instruction like add or
subtract or multiply at the very end of
all of this what we have is a script a
computer program which is human readable
which can execute on the processor and
draw a window draw a button on the
screen we've gone from a switch and a
series of ones and zeros electrons
transistors quantum mechanics all the
way to having pixels drawn on a screen
in what five ten steps and it's simple
layers of abstraction and it allows us
to talk about computers at an
appropriate level so that we don't have
to understand all of the quantum
mechanics every time I want to draw a
button on the screen because it would
just be unwieldy I have an iPhone right
I don't think that's going to be a
surprise to anybody although by the way
I much prefer the Windows Phone and I
know that my nephew's have got smart
phones and I see a lot of kids using
games consoles and smart phones these
things don't encourage you to understand
what's going on under the hood I mean
here is a really slick piece of
engineering and it's completely closed
it's a black box what we've done is
we've abstracted the concept of a
computer to the point where it's one
single black box and I don't need to
understand how any of this works all I
need to know and this is amazing I mean
plaudits to Apple for this all I need to
know is that this one button does
everything I press this button and it
does everything which is a remarkable
achievement that is what abstraction can
do for you but it worries me as an
engineer and as a scientist that if this
is what kids are growing up with what is
it that's encouraging them to ask the
question how does this work where's the
new generation of engineers and
scientists and people who want to take
this apart there's not even a screw I
can take out
with people who want to take this apart
and see how it works going to come from
if there's not a screw that I can take
out the back and have a really good feel
around inside
I remember my acorn electron it appeared
in other videos doesn't that satisfy the
biggest blackest piece of beauty you
could possibly imagine it had a terribly
non economic keyboard crucially it had
screws in the back and I could take them
out and I could open it up and I could
see how this thing worked or I could
begin to imagine how this thing worked
and that's what fired the imagination of
an eleven-year-old James today I know
it's a really difficult thing to say how
do you take a child and you introduce
them to the concept of the ones and the
zeroes which are underlying the computer
I am a computer file like this I can't
wait to do these videos but we can't
talk about anything without first of all
defining our Terms right